welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the mandalorian has been so
damn great we're gonna break down
Chapter two just the Star Wars
connections and Easter eggs but the
visual symbolism in cinema collages that
were snuck into the imagery and of
course some theories for why baby Yoda
is so important other than holiday gift
sales please give me what I want I'm a
little behind on this one I'm
essentially on triple time producing
three watches of the first two Star Wars
trilogies and banking some really
exciting contact for the holidays not
getting much sleep but we're here before
chapter 3 came out so mission
accomplished enough about my mental
state on to the episode and boiler
warning in case we haven't seen it yet
the episode opens on this lizard it's
almost exactly like the opening shot of
Mad Max fury road my favorite movie of
this decade maybe of every decade but
rather than stop on this lizard eating
it raw this road warrior scares a
tapasya squirts baby Oda now this
probably isn't the Yoda though I did
spend a pretty wild theory about how it
could be in last week's episode of rogue
theory but notice species is unknown a
plot line and Star Wars rebels featured
them scouring the galaxy for a force
sensitive babies this could be part of
that plan others have noted that the
patch worn by doctor / Shane who
companion to Verna Herzog's the client
resembles the emblem of Kamino the
planet of the cloning facility in attack
of the clones so perhaps that fuels the
whole Yoda clone theory but away from
crackpot corner of the rogue theory
table I'm now betting that this baby
Yoda is an unrelated member of the Yoda
species this appearance alone is enough
to evoke nostalgia we don't need a
direct familial relation there's just
too much symbolism in that floating pod
it's clearly designed to evoke an egg
further underlined the fragility of this
infant and in order to avoid having to
trade this egg to the Jawas to get his
ship parts back mando must retrieve for
them another sugar egg yummy suger like
another thing you can blood let your
precious time to on disney + wall-e
they're using the egg imagery here to
contrast a barren death scape
to suggest the promise of something new
and I think making baby Yoda
Yodas baby here we go to his clone or
Yoda himself would contradict that neo
symbolism man deceives maybe Oda from a
few trend oceans presumably the same
bounty hunters who clocked him back in
episode 1 now these are the same race of
the Bounty Hunter Bosque
from Empire Strikes Back I love how the
visuals hint at their ambush first just
a subtle shadow as they leap overhead
and then on the reflection of mandos
helmet as heat
cool as this helmet is like baby Yoda's
egg it's also a shell that's equally
protective and prohibitive in mandos
cases cutting off its peripheral vision
a freaking blur got the drop on them
last episode the saying that things got
a lot of blind spots when mando shoots
with his rifle his targets disintegrate
leaves their clothes behind this tech
dates back to that bounty hunters scene
in Empire which seems to have inspired
this whole series but I want them know
disintegration mando sees that the
trained oceans were given the same
locator for baby Yoda that he was
signaling to him that like IG 11 several
bounty hunters were deployed perhaps the
client wants to cover his bases or other
paying clients or after the same thing
baby Oda tries to heal mandos wound but
not understanding mando pushes them back
it's kind of similar to the healing
powers of ET which is an alien species
that technically exists in the Star Wars
universe from that background Easter egg
in the Phantom Menace and ET excitedly
following a kid in the Yoda costume
saying oh man defines Jawas stripping
his ship for their sand crawler like the
one they had on Tatooine but I doubt
this planet is Tatooine it rains here
and Tatooine orbits binary stars at
scorch it so that it's really only
habitable at its poles solids can
generally be found on several planets
it's interesting how the Jawas
communicate via landline transmitting to
the helm via this horn it voc's
old-school ships I also love how willing
the Jawas are to sacrifice their own
parts to shake off mando from throwing
scraps at him to knocking off their
crane extension because they're
scavengers I'll just buy new junk to
replace it all they stuck mando and he
freezes it tips over it's perfect he's
doing an impression of r2d2 when he was
stunned by JA was in the first Star Wars
film before continue thank you to the
ridge for sponsoring this episode the
rich makes everyday goods to a standard
you don't see every day they streamline
your life by turning the things you
carry like backpacks chargers and
wallets into tools for better living
their flagship product the ridge wallet
was launched on Kickstarter in 2013 and
now sits in the front pockets of over a
half million men and women I developed
George Costanza back problems from an
overstuffed wallet but not for money it
was like receipts napkins I found some
hand sanitizer in there but now I got
this baby where it's leakin Taine's all
the cards that you need and can
this is their aluminum wallet in a raw
color they have other colors including
some very flashy Tiki designs light it's
strong and as a cool industrial chic
vibe the ridge is a minimal front pocket
wallet that's designed to streamline
what you carry every day
it has 30,000 five-star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash and cards
there's a lifetime warranty if you love
it and free returns if you don't it
comes to titanium carbon fiber aluminum
in a dozen different styles and colors
we also got there when approved commuter
backpack that comes with a shock
resistant laptop holder and a hidden
RFID blocking pockets tip 10% off today
with free worldwide shipping and returns
by going to Ridge comm slash new rock
stars
that's ridge comm slash new rock stars
and use the code new rock stars and you
can find the link in the description
below
these were Korean wide landscapes of man
dough with baby Yoda evoke the imagery
of classics like Lawrence of Arabia and
the westerns of John Ford and Sergio
Leone all major influences on the
original trilogy films he returns to
queal the Ignite played by Nick Nolte if
you remember AG knots first appeared on
Cloud City they're hard workers who
often end up in servant roles baby Oda
eats a frog whole similar to how Jabba
the Hutt eats a frog and return the Jedi
so maybe Jabba's is dead baby Oda burps
and giggles
justing that even at the young age of 50
this species has the same goofy sense of
humor shown by Yoda when we first met
him right now the Jawas scrap pile
contains an r5 astromech unit similar to
the one seen in Star Wars the one that
caught fire when uncle Owen tried to buy
it and a new droid that shares parts
with a medical unit similar to the one
that operated on Vader in Revenge of the
Sith remember the one that he forced
smushed before he moved mando says that
weapons are part of his religion
referring to the ancient customs of the
people of Mandalore whose people have
survived by adhering to warrior
traditions it's also why you equally
vehemently refuses to trade it's best
scar armor it's all sacred to him and
his people they mock a man whose ability
to speak Java as saying he sounds like a
Wookiee keeping up with the tradition of
everyone in the Star Wars universe
[ __ ] on bookies where are you taking
this thing somebody get this big walking
carpet out of my way
to retrieve these so yeah mando must
fight a rhinoceros type creature
adapting the whole mythological quests
of slaying the dragon to retrieve the
gold now this creature is fur-covered
applying the pachyderm evolution logic
of the elephant's ancestor the woolly
mammoth the Rhino reveals itself with
the opening of a huge eye were shattered
by the eye shape of the cave entrance I
was actually seeing this similar trope
of giant beasts opening their eyes to
surprise people and movies like Godzilla
in Jurassic Park films mando holds out a
knife hopelessly as death closes in but
he saved at the last second by a deus ex
machina baby Yoda using the force kind
of similar to that moment in Saving
Private Ryan captain Miller hopelessly
firing its pistol at the German taste
till one explodes saved miraculously by
the American planes overhead baby Yoda
is exerting roughly the same energy that
the real Yoda used to lift the x-wing
from the Dagobah swamp if you listen
closely the composer Ludwig your inson
underscores this miracle with the
subtlest light motif to John Williams
force theme
[Music]
mando is mystified by this as his Kuya
when he hears about it reflecting the
requried skepticism toward the force
throughout the Star Wars universe from
ha and laughing and obi-wan space to Rey
thinking Luke Skywalker was a myth and
as they repair the ship I love how the
super imposing cross dissolves create
the illusion of the sparks of their
tools appearing to be fixing baby Yoda
as it sleeps as if restoring it back to
health - now despite the ending with
baby Yoda finally awakening from his
power nap this episode ends on a notably
darker tone than chapter 1 because queal
denies payment for his generosity but he
does say this thank you for bringing
peached
valley to me this suggests that as
adorable as this thing is it brings
nothing but violence wherever it goes
violence that mando is now carrying with
him subscribed in new rock stars here on
YouTube for more Star Wars analysis and
follow me Eddie hey boss thanks for
joining me and I think suga's
[Music]